[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening that's pretty incredible
throughout time we've been looking at
ways in which machines can improve and
change our lives
I'm dr. rich Besser from ABC News and
tonight we're gonna be looking at the
ways that people have tried to use
machines to improve the function of our
brains we have with us on the panel some
of the leading experts in this field to
get us started in to set the stage what
I want to do is is go back over some
some histories first looking at the ways
people have used electricity to change
and understand some of our basic human
functions to some of the more recent
efforts to try and use electricity to
enhance our brains around the same time
that Benjamin Franklin was conducting
his groundbreaking experiments Italian
physician physicist and philosopher
Luigi Galvani he was making some
discoveries of his own when he zapped
the muscles in a dead frog's leg with an
electric spark they twitched and he
called this discovery animal electricity
well in 1803 a public demonstration of
his work was done with the corpse of an
executed criminal and a local writer
described it this way I hope there's no
children in the audience on the first
application of the process to the face
the jaws of the deceased criminal began
to quiver and the adjoining muscles were
horribly contorted one eye was actually
opened in the subsequent part of the
process the right hand was raised and
clenched and the legs and thighs were
set in motion writers like Mary Shelley
found Galvani's work inspiring and we
found it frightening half a century
later Guillaume Duchenne explored the
neural pathways of live patients to
understand how the muscles in the human
face produce expression he used a
leftover electrical probes to create
grotesque looking spasms which he
recorded with the recently invented
camera but perhaps the most publicized
form of electrical stimulation is
electroconvulsive therapy ECT in which
patients
are treated with an electrical current
that induces a full seizure a grand mal
seizure this was developed in the 1940s
and it was widely used to treat
depression until the antidepressants
revolutionized the approach to mental
illness pills for depression were in
electrical stimulation for most patients
with depression was out drug treatment
wasn't limited however to treating
mental illness yes
drugs were were developed to fight
depression and to fight anxiety but
there were also drugs that were looking
at enhancing performance making us
stronger and faster even drugs to
enhance our performance yes and drugs to
enhance our performance in the bedroom
on campuses drugs like adderall ritalin
in medellín have become favorites of
some college students who've looked for
that cognitive edge but today we're not
gonna be talking about drugs we're gonna
be talking about zapping the brain and
zapping the brain is having a comeback
unlike electric shock of the past the
new technology sends mild electrical or
magnetic current directly into specific
areas of the brain in labs around the
world researchers are exploring use of
brain stimulation with brain disorders
including stroke and depression but also
in brains that are not not suffering
from disorders the military is using it
on normal brains to increase vigilance
in those people who are operating drones
but this is a barely regulated
technology in fact you can go on the web
I went on the web this afternoon to this
website focus and it's a favorite among
gamers and a number of the interns in
the office went to the site too and were
blown away that you can go online and
you can buy a devices put it onto your
head turn on the current
and play your video games without
regulation there's very little
regulation here right now it's basically
the wild wild west
so the question how effective is this
technology are there any side effects is
there any downside to doing this is
brain enhancement even ethical the use
of any kind of brain enhancement whether
it's pills or zapping the brain brings
myriad ethical and moral issues we're
gonna be exploring those but let's face
it we enhance our brain function all the
time I start the morning with a cup of
coffee it gets me going some people play
music to the developing fetus when when
they're pregnant we read to our kids to
improve their comprehension and improve
their brain function so where's the line
between appropriate brain enhancement
and brain enhancement that we think
there may be a little something wrong
with this so these are some of the
issues that we're gonna be dealing with
tonight so I want to go ahead and
introduce our distinguished panel our
our first participant is a professor of
law and philosophy at Duke University
she is the director of the Duke science
and society program in 2010 she was
appointed by President Obama to this
Presidential Commission for the study of
bioethical issues and continues to serve
as a member she's a widely published
scholar on the ethical legal and social
implications of the Biosciences and
emerging technologies please welcome
Nita
Bharani
our next participant is professor
emeritus at the University of California
Irvine School of Medicine he's also the
associate editor of the intelligence
journal and the president-elect of the
International Society for intelligence
research his main research interest uses
neuroimaging to investigate the
structural and functional neuroanatomy
of higher cognitive processes especially
human intelligence please welcome
Richard hier
[Applause]
[Music]
and our third panelist tonight a
neuroscientist whose research uses
structural and functional neuroimaging
to investigate normal memory epilepsy
mental illness and cognitive dysfunction
his team developed novel approaches and
technologies that combine neuro imaging
with transcranial direct current
stimulation tDCS to enhance learning and
vigilance in civilian and military
subjects please welcome Michael license
[Applause]
now originally we had a fourth panelist
Alvaro Pasquale leone due to problems
with not george airline or whether i
should mention it he was stuck on the
runway for hours and is unable to join
us but the team will will cover some of
his material during during the
presentation first richard i wanted to
start with you
you know we want to try and understand
how you can use electricity to to alter
the brain without doing something as as
drastic as electro convulsive therapy
and there's this concept of
neuroplasticity and could you could you
take us through this area
well neuroplasticity is just a simple
concept that the brain changes now this
might not seem like a shocking
revelation but in fact it was really
quite a surprise to researchers who for
many years believe the brain was
essentially static we now know that the
brain changes its function and its
structure and it's modified by
experience and we can measure these
things with brain imaging and i was able
to do a study on this way back in
nineteen ninety two is one of the first
brain imaging studies of learning we
were interested in what takes place in
the brain when when a person learns
something and for the something we
decided to study the computer game
tetris and back in 1992 when we did this
no one had ever heard of tetris no one
had a personal computer to play at home
so I got a copy of Tetris and people
came to my office every day and
practiced for an hour and we knew they
weren't practicing at home because they
couldn't
I had one of the rare personal computers
at the time and the idea was to do a
brain scan before and after people learn
Tetris now if you don't know Tetris this
graphic shows you that individual shapes
appear at the top of the screen and
slowly fall to the bottom and as they
fall you use the arrow keys to move them
right left or bring them down
the object is to complete rows with no
gaps whenever those rows are complete
you get a point for that row that row
disappears and all the shapes above drop
down changing the configuration you're
watching
Danny's mom play Danny's mom had never
played Tetris before and this is her
first game and you can see the goal in
this particular version of Tetris is to
see how fast you can complete 40 lines
so you can see the seconds ticking away
there on the left and right below you
can see it looks like she has from here
about 38 lines to go she's completed -
so you all get the idea and almost
everybody knows Tetris and here's what
the brain images look like when people
were naive that is before they they
practice the first time they played the
game we did a brain image with positron
emission tomography or PET scanning
showing where radioactive glucose went
in the brain while they were playing and
the red colors in this image show where
the brain is most active and you can see
very clearly after 50 days of practice
when the game is faster and harder and
and clearly more difficult making
decisions in fact there's less brain
activity and this was an indication that
learning makes the brain efficient and
we have spent many years since we
published this in 1992 trying to
understand what it is about the brain
that really is efficient then about 2008
I got a call from the company that owned
Tetris and they had just discovered this
1992 paper and they said would you like
to try to replicate it will be happy to
fund it
and so naturally I said yes and in the
next slide you will see the results of
our replication study this was studying
adolescent girls who were not interested
in computer games it was harder to find
people who didn't know tetris now but
these adolescent girls really had were
not gamers at all and what we found
after they trained on tetris for three
months was something really unexpected
the the blue areas show functional MRI
showing functional brain plasticity and
it the blue areas show where the brain
was less active after after practice so
functionally the blue areas became less
active the red areas show where there
was an increase in gray matter I had
forgot to tell you that this was
inspired by a juggling study where
structural MRIs had in fact shown that
gray matter actually increases in people
who had never juggled before when they
learned to juggle and practice for three
months there's actually more gray matter
in the in their motor cortex so we heard
about this and we said jeez I wonder if
motor activity that changes gray matter
what about cognitive activity let's
reprise the Tetris experiment and the
tetris company was happy to fund this so
going back now to the the red areas in
the blue areas the red areas are where
there was more grey matter after three
months of practice and what's really
remarkable about this picture is you see
there's no overlap between the red areas
and the blue areas we thought the brain
would become more efficient in those
spots where there was more grey matter
now why there's no overlap as a mystery
between functional plasticity and
structural plasticity so now because of
this concept of plasticity there have
been a lot of claims that you can change
the brain and make people smarter you
can actually increase intelligence that
experience changes the brain the brain
is plastic so why not make people
smarter and one of the first examples of
this was 1990
when a group published a paper claiming
an increase in IQ after listening to a
particular piece of music he recognized
this Mozart Sonata listen to this for a
few seconds do you feel smarter anybody
else feel smarter so this really took
the scientific world and the public by
storm that you could become smarter
higher IQ just by listening to Mozart at
the time in 1993 the governor of Georgia
heard about this and got their state
legislature to appropriate money to buy
Mozart CDs to give to every mother of
the newborn baby in the state of Georgia
so here we are some years later iq has
not changed this is now referred to as
the schmutz art effect because in fact
it really couldn't be replicated but it
took years every high school science
fair I went to when my kids were growing
up had a Mozart experiment and I'm sure
these were all over the country but in
truth it didn't work but it was an
example of brain plasticity
now there's another fad that is getting
a lot of media attention about training
short-term memory and that is claim that
makes your IQ go up there are now
replication studies that show this is
not the case but nonetheless it's still
out there in the popular press this is
an example of the short term memory test
that people were trained on for a couple
of months this is a little confusing so
let me explain ignore the things moving
across the top of the screen and just
look at the matrix of nine cells at the
bottom of the screen every once in a
while you'll see one of those will light
up you have to remember the position of
the cell that lights up and then the
next cell lights up and when the third
cell lights up if that position was
identical to the first one it
other words to back you press the button
so now when we play it we're for
demonstration purposes only showing you
the trials across the top and you can
see whenever there are identical trials
with one in between you press the button
now this is called the end back test
where n stands for a number like 1 or 2
or 3 if it's and back 1 2 trials that
are identical in a row you press the
button 2 back there has to be an
intervening trial 3 back 2 intervening
trials you can imagine what this is like
for 4 back or 5 back and the claim is if
you train people to do this so they get
four or five or even six back their IQ
goes up the confusion there are many
confusions but one is that short-term
memory is identical with IQ short-term
memory is important for intelligence but
it's not the same thing and I'm going to
demonstrate that to you in this 2-minute
video clip the scientists at Japan's
Primate Research Institute the PRI where
au mu is based have devised intelligence
tests for chimps one test is for what's
called working memory the brain's
ability to temporarily store and use
information the numbers 1 to 9 are
randomly scattered across a touchscreen
the chimp looks at them for as long as
is needed to memorize the layout then as
soon as one is touched the other numbers
are hidden and must now be remembered we
volunteered Chris the director of this
program to demonstrate this test he's a
college graduate and a crossword addict
but how good is his working memory
when Chris reckons he has memorized the
layout he touches one when the others
are hidden he must try to recall two to
nine in ascending order it takes me ages
to remember where they're all placed and
then I think I've got it it's really
very very difficult in 30 attempts Chris
only once reached nine without making a
mistake as soon as they're blanked over
it's like my mind's been blanked over as
well when are you moose at the same test
he correctly remembered the numbers
almost 90% of the time ie almost every
time and I've got it right
once Chris fears he's let his species
down but even when the PRI played a
youmu against their best human students
who were giving regular practice
sessions are you moose still beat all
humans
so clearly memory is not the same as
intelligence so I have a challenge for
people who make claims about enhancing
cognition I have two of them the first
one is show me enhancing cognition in a
human so he can beat that chimp and the
second one is illustrated in the final
video I'm going to show you of another
person playing Tetris in world-champion
this is not sped up real
remember the object is to get 40 lines
in this little time as possible it's a
real human being it's not the chimp so
the second challenge is to get Danny's
mom to play like this
using electrical stimulation or anything
else I would like to see that oh thank
you that's brain plasticity we had
planned at this point for dr. Pasquale
Leonie to present some of his work on
using electrical stimulation to try and
and address the challenge that Richard
just just gave us so Richards gonna
present some of Alvaro's work now yes
he's done that
among others two classic experiments
that I know he was going to introduce
today so Bri fill out briefly I'll just
tell you what they are in the the first
was a brain imaging experiment done in a
person who was blind
this person had no vision from from
birth and this these brain images showed
this person's brain activation while
they did three different tasks these are
obviously not visual tasks but the point
is in each of these three tasks is
included a memory task in a verbal task
in all of them you see the visual cortex
the back of the brain is activated in a
person who never used the visual cortex
to see this is a very nice demonstration
of functional plasticity that the visual
cortex when not used for vision can be
used for other things it takes a little
bit of time for the brain to adjust and
that's what's illustrated in the next
in the next experiment that he did with
a normal volunteer who stayed
blindfolded for weeks and at the end of
a only actually was dazed at the end of
the second day that would be some
volunteer wouldn't it so on the end of
the second day what you can see is the
the bottom image bottom right hand image
in the back of the brain on the bottom
there you see this person's visual
cortex is now activated doing non visual
things so another demonstration that in
a person with normal sight if the brain
is deprived of that sight for a
relatively short period of time the
cortex changes and it can be
reprogrammed if you will to do other
things so I know those are the two
things he was going to start with like
one of the one of the things that we
want to lay out for people to understand
is the different types of stimulation of
the the brain that are being explored
and so if you could could explain to us
what the difference is between tDCS and
TMS yeah so the tDCS
is one species of electrical brain
stimulation TMS is magnetic brain
stimulation in tDCS or and other forms
of electrical stimulation what happens
is the brain is an electrical organ so
it makes all kinds of sense if you want
to change it you should you can't apply
electricity to do that now most of us
are no strangers to changing our brains
if you had a cup of coffee this morning
or if you had some other drug that helps
you deal with some health issue you're
very likely affecting your brain what
we're doing here is trying to affect
only the brain and leave your heart and
your lungs and your kidneys and your
liver to do their jobs right so
electrical brain stimulation can come in
three forms those three forms are a DC
current a DC current Ram
up stays level and then ramps down at
the end of stimulation AC current puts
in a sine wave or a wave that travels up
and down like this and trns another type
of stimulation that's in the literature
puts in a string of random values and
changes the electrical activity that's
traveling through the brain accordingly
TMS now is a different kind of brain
activity or a different kind of brain
stimulation TMS is delivered as a square
wave okay square wave means you're flat
then you come up you go back down this
the square wave the width of that square
wave is typically on the order of
milliseconds or thousandths of a second
right the electrical brain stimulation
methods we've been talking about what
they do is they change the brain level
of activity or a level of excitability
from low to slightly higher and
essentially turn up the gain on the
environment is the idea so that when you
see a light it's a little brighter or
when you see a or when you hear a sound
it's a little more salient among all the
other stimuli that are in the
environment TMS is different
TMS puts in the square wave and that
directly activates or forces neurons to
be active okay so in TMS you put in a
magnetic current and it influences the
underlying electricity and it depends on
how frequently you repeat that square
wave to in terms of the cognitive effect
you get with low frequencies of
repeating a square wave for example once
per second you get a decrease in the
excitability of the brain with higher
rates like ten Hertz or ten stimulations
per second you get an increase in the
activity
so a lot of the technology we're talking
about is is really in the early
experimental phases but but not all of
it the the TMS the magnetic stimulation
you were just hearing about it has
already been FDA approved for the
treatment of depression and we want to
show you a little video here of the
experience of one New York hero in in
using that treatment I guess everybody
wants to be a firefighter when they grow
up you want to help people love doing
the job and thought that I would be
doing the job for 30 years or more when
we first got down on the pile it was a
bit overwhelming because it was such a
huge mess just the amazing amount of
destruction that was in front of you you
know you really got to see the the sight
the smell the taste of the magnitude of
the destruction that was there things
started to go downhill at first and then
things got really bad where I was in a
very deep depression I pulled away from
my family and friends I slept a lot I
was suicidal at a point there was only
one way out of it and it wasn't it
wasn't good I worked with the
psychiatrist for the fire department I
don't remember how many but there was
probably eight or ten different
medications that we had tried at the
point where he asked me to retire he
said that he had gone through everything
that he had in his playbook I guess to
try and relieve some of my symptoms
I lost my dream job I needed to do
something to help I just thought that
trying TMS was definitely worth a shot
you just sit in the chair you get the
treatment which feels like somebody
tapping on your head
really fast it's just short bursts of
the pulses within the first two weeks
there was a little bit of a change I
started just waking up in the morning
before my alarm clock and got up and
ready for the day I was sleeping better
at night
I wish the treatment was available to me
before I had to retire I think it would
have made a huge impact on how I
responded and I believe that I probably
could have stayed on the job and
continued to being a firefighter well
although that's approved by the FDA for
use it's really not fully understood how
that that modality treats treats
depression we want a shift now to
talking about the one of the other
modalities that Michael talked about
tDCS and Michael eyesand
is an expert in this area he's been
conducting research on this technology
and and it's used to increase the
vigilant in in drone operators how does
that work so first I'd like to say
thanks to all the people that watch our
backs
so that we can sit here in relative
safety and comfort and have this
conversation so and those people need
help they in the video you just saw you
saw the
Effects of missing intelligence signals
that were clearly there in the
after-action reports and we need help in
doing this better so we were approached
years ago we applied to a I'm received
funding from DARPA to investigate ways
in which we could accelerate training to
find the signals that people might
identify to prevent things like the
attacks that occurred on 9/11 one way to
do that is to stimulate the brains of
people who are looking at these pictures
so when you guys look at pictures you're
only capable of one percept at a time
all right and that one percept at a time
is often shown in lots of visual
illusions that you see and I think we
have an example of one here so how many
people see a vase how many people see
two people looking at one another can
you see them both at the same time
that's it's very difficult if you can
it's your special brain the so in this
case the brain acts as a winner-take-all
system all right one visual percept at a
time now the people that are examining
images to try to find threats are
basically playing a game of Where's
Waldo right is there a threat in this
image or not and they may look at a
whole book of Where's Waldo or an image
something like this right where you have
to find something specific if I told you
in this figure to find let's see can I
pick something right here so does
everybody see the deck of car that now
the game cards how about the Barbie
how about the Dora yeah all right so now
what if I ask you to find the wrecked
car yeah so this is a game that our
intelligence analysts play all day every
day and they play it for 12 to 14 on 12
to 14 hour shifts now imagine doing that
constantly for 12 to 14 hours all right
it's a big job and we may and the thing
that you're looking for may not be in
the image right okay so we have some
examples of those images I think that we
are going to show you this is what's
called a target chip this is in the this
was one of the training images that we
used when we were doing the study so who
knows what that is
that is a Humvee image from about five
miles away all right so now if we go to
the next image we can now does everybody
see the Humvee here this is one of the
easy target images all right everybody
don't be here all right so if we go to
the next image you will identify the
Humvee for you there it is a up Hemet
310 right there okay so now let's go to
a medium image so this is the medium
image you guys all see the Humvee
all right so the Humvee I believe in
this one is over on the left well no I
was wrong the Humvee is on the right the
missile launchers on the left all right
and that's a medium image now we have a
difficult image all right everybody see
the Humvee and the missile launcher all
right but this is what our guys in
uniform are doing 12 to 14 hours a day
every day and then getting off work and
going to soccer practice right so they
need help all right if you guys had
difficulty doing this the people who we
take out of high school run through boot
camp do a few schools with and sit down
in front of a computer screen are gonna
have the same and/or greater difficulty
so what are the results does this thing
work right so if you look at the green
bar these images show the number of
correct identifications of targets Oh
divided by the number of false alarms
okay so at a value of 2.5 here means
that you are correct two and a half more
times than you are wrong the green bar
shows training alone the blue bar shows
training plus putting all the gear on
your head but not turning it on it's
called sham stimulation and the red bar
shows training plus stimulation we can
dramatically change how good people are
at this task after a short amount of
training okay so we trained what we did
in particular in the studies we showed
him images like you just saw we showed
them the target chips for an hour and
then we embedded those thar
chips into the city scenes that you saw
and without stimulation roughly two and
a half to three times better after the
training with stimulation about seven
times better with one hour of training
on the target chips destiny well Michael
has has has demonstrated that this
technology can can work it can have a
positive effect but they're their
questions in terms of when should this
be used who should it be used by what
are the ethical implications of this and
bioethicists Nita fara Hani is writing a
book on just that subject tDCS as well
as other types of electrical stimulation
fit just within a category a very broad
category of ways in which we can enhance
our brains so that's you know why many
of you are here this evening is to
enhance your brains to learn something
about this topic we go to school we eat
good nutrition hopefully sometimes we
exercise all of those things are really
designed to improve our health to
improve our mental functioning to
improve our cognitive functioning so as
a baseline there's nothing wrong and
everything right with us as humans
trying to improve our cognition but the
question is when is it appropriate to do
so when you have a new and novel kind of
technology particularly something like
tDCS who should have access to it if all
of you came here this evening and for
the first time you're learning about
tDCS should you have in your hands a
consumer-based tDCS device that you
could apply to your head then up or amp
up what's happening in your brains are
there any concerns about that should
there be regulation of it should there
be instructions or informational
guidelines that are given to you
and what's the context in which it's
okay or when it's not okay to use it so
you know consider this and we'll start
with just I think a couple of images to
sort of pique people's thinking about
these ethical issues so how many of you
had a cup of coffee or tea at some point
today most of you how many of you never
drink any form of caffeine or eat any
form of caffeine so no chocolate either
right so so again how many of you never
consumed any form of caffeine no
chocolate really all right I bet we
could find some caffeine in your diet
and somewhere but in any event why are
we okay with the vast majority of you
using a stimulant every day of your life
when did we come as a society to think
that that's a permissible form of
cognition cognitive enhancement where
this fellow in the front row either
doesn't like it or can't tolerate it or
for whatever reason he's not enhancing
his brain the way the rest of you are
when did we come to embrace that as
something that was permissible and good
to do and is there any difference
between us all having a cup of coffee
versus zapping our brains is it really
just the same thing is it all just on a
kind of gradients of what we consider to
be permissible versus impermissible use
well we know at least in one context
that we're not okay
with certain forms of enhancement right
so if you pay to go to a sporting events
what you're paying for is seeing natural
honed talent whatever that might mean
right it is a person who has some sort
of natural gifts that has worked hard to
improve their gifts and therefore there
are great cyclists as opposed to one who
is a doped up cyclist or they're a great
pitcher or they're a great batter or
they can dunk a basketball whatever they
can do they can do without taking
steroids and without taking drugs and
without doing things that artificially
enhance okay and we've come to decide
that that's what we want to celebrate
okay that's what sports are about just
like we all
celebrate baseball and we're not that
excited when we discover that our
baseball pitchers are actually doping or
our baseball batters or doping so the
homeruns aren't just exciting we could
decide otherwise
as a society we could come to think
actually instead of watching baseball we
want to watch baseball and SH baseball
is a league in which everybody dopes
okay
and it turns out all they do is hit
homeruns and I bet if we put it out
there and you all got to decide do you
want to buy tickets to SH baseball or do
you want to buy tickets to baseball
market forces would help us decide which
league should actually exist and in fact
we have something sort of like that
what's the wrestling fat you know
worldwide whatever that one is that's
not real I'm sorry to break it all to
you yeah it's not real
but nevertheless people still pay big
money to watch those sporting events
okay but in that context we've decided
at least for now until we have spaceball
that we don't want to watch baseball we
want to watch baseball
what about standardized tests so what
are standardized tests measuring I'm not
quite sure but supposedly they are good
predictors of how well you're gonna do
in college or how well you're gonna do
in second grade or how well you're gonna
do in law school or any other kind of
thing it supposed to give us a baseline
by which we compare individuals and as
most of you are aware whether it's in
high school or in college or even at
younger levels people are already
starting to take drugs like adderall or
other types of drugs like ritalin the
drugs which are stimulants before they
take the task in order to prepare or
study for that test is that cheating
I hear and no but it is that cheating
think about it for just a minute in in
sports it's cheating because it's
artificial enhancement is it cheating if
it's for standardized test is it
cheating if we start applying tDCS while
you study for the test tDCS alone is not
going to make you smarter but it could
potentially make you identify targets
faster and maybe those targets are the
vocab matching words or logic games or
things like that if you do it while
you're learning it may improve your
ability to take certain types of tasks
at Duke University it's the first
University in the country that put into
its cheating policy taking off taking
prescription drugs for which you do not
have a prescription for enhancement
purposes to improve your performance I
I wasn't part of that decision so I'm
not saying that it is a good decision
but certainly one University has put a
stake in the ground and said it's
cheating to do so is it cheating to have
tDCS
is it not so it let's look at the next
slide what what this image is is helping
you it's not it's not just a benevolent
parent who's helping their child but it
should evoke for you a little bit the
conversation that happens to society
about Tiger parents some of you in this
audience might be Tiger parents and if
you were Tiger parents and you had in
your hands a tDCS unit and you could
apply it to your young child and you
have a promise that they would do better
on standardized tests and we're here in
New York so I know that there's this
crazy competition to get into schools
here in New York so what if I could tell
you that if you apply to DCs to your
child while they're taking the
standardized test they're gonna do
better and get into the preschool that
will make sure that they get into the
elementary school that will make sure
that they get into the college and have
a successful career on Wall Street right
would you use it well they might and is
that okay
right so parents all the time are making
decisions for their children that
enhance their cognition in particular
ways they're taking them to dance
lessons or taking them to music lessons
maybe they're letting them listen to
mozart or even learn to play Mozart they
are getting them tutors they are giving
them good nutrition they're encouraging
them to exercise all of these things
enhance their brains but most of those
things we understand at least within a
certain parameter what the risks and
benefits are now some of them we
understand the risk may be that you're
ensuring that your child's gonna spend a
lot of years in therapy later in life
but what we might not realize with tDCS
is we don't know what the full scope of
the rest and benefits are so if you
looking at the next slide were to apply
tDCS and it increases the activity the
baseline activity in a particular region
of the brain because you're putting it
in specific spots if energy is conserved
in some way which is supposed to be does
that mean that it's decreasing
activation in some other region of your
brain and so what this is showing you
right now is the amygdala the amygdala
at least before a paper came out this
week and suggested maybe all of the
studies are wrong
supposedly is the area of the brain
that's really essential for moral
conscience and for emotion and if you
have decreased activation in the
amygdala then so the theory goes you are
less likely to have moral conscience you
are less likely to be an empathetic
individual less likely to have emotion
so suppose you have a child who you
decide you really want to get into that
super competitive preschool here in New
York City and you start applying tDCS to
them which leads to decrease activation
in a different area of the brain and it
happens to be a decreased area called
the amygdala are you in fact just
producing a little psychopath maybe so
psychopaths in part are really smart and
lack moral conscience and emotional
processing what's the consequence and
risk of doing so and should parents get
to shape the brains of their children in
this way
you already shape the brains of your
child if you're a parent in many ways
but is this way this altering the
structure and functions so directly one
that's ethically permissible or so the
regulations or limitations on who or
when you use those types of technologies
there are host of ethical issues that
are involved with all of the different
cognitive enhancement technologies one
that we're talking about is electrodes
to electrical stimulation but it doesn't
have to be that kind of hard stimulation
that we're talking about there are other
devices that are already on the market
just like there are tDCS units that are
on the market that could enable you
through neurofeedback to improve your
cognition as well so we're actually
gonna do a little demonstration I think
of that yeah and see you know just to
half people have a sense of like what
are the devices that are out there what
are the things that you can do to your
brain and I think I need another little
help here to make this happen
excellent thank you and I have a willing
victim up here which is great since he
does these other devices
I thought we could go ahead and just see
his brain and see what he's done to his
brain with all the devices that he's
been testing in his lab so what I'm
hooking up to him right here is a really
simple
EEG device okay which measures
electrical activity and brain and this
is actually just gonna measure through
the single electrode right here that is
on his forehead you see that little
device right there and it's grounded
over here on his ear
is that comfortable I bet yeah so what
we're gonna measure is just really
simple alpha and beta waves which
correlate to attention and meditation
and we're gonna look at how well he can
pay attention while all of you are
watching okay and so we're gonna go to
the screen here and what you're gonna
see is his brain activity so what he
wants to do is have as much green as
possible and
[Music]
as he gets higher up if he can he's
gonna get a little neurofeedback because
you're gonna hear the Seto
okay let's all be let's all be very
quiet if you can pay attention for a
minute
[Music]
that's pretty good that's pretty good
right we should give him a little round
of live
if he were to continue working with this
device for a while what he would do is
be able to get in that green band much
more quickly and much more regularly and
what that may correlate with is an
increased ability to pay attention and
things like school or watching his
Facebook page or any other activity
which might require increased attention
and concentration which is a form of
enhancement and in fact when they've
done studies to see whether or not this
in fact changes your brain it in fact
also just like the images that we saw
earlier changes the gray matter in your
brain when you do neurofeedback like
this that's neat
do you wonder how it is that we got it
up there on the screen yeah so real time
you were watching his brain activity and
his brain activity was being recorded
through that electrical signal through
the electrode right here which was a dry
electrode which was communicating to the
iPad that they brought out here which
they wouldn't have had to bring out here
they just wanted me to be able to see it
and interact with it because the range
was long enough to go back there because
it was communicating via bluetooth and
many of your devices communicate via
bluetooth right and how secure do you
think Bluetooth is not particularly
secure and this is not a terribly
frightening device because it's not
actually applying electrical current so
even though he willingly let me put it
on to his brain I couldn't SAP his brain
I could start to see some of the neural
signatures that were in his brain and I
could start to see for example if he was
getting drowsy or if he was paying
attention you all saw him stopping
paying attention I don't know what he
was looking at instead of actually
participating in the experiment for us
but imagine now if you're in the
workplace and we can require you to wear
this all day long
know how much you're paying attention
how distracted you are imagine if your
neural signature could help us figure
out what your ATM password is you don't
have to imagine too much about these
things because they already are true
we're already using neural signatures
for passwords to be able to unlock
devices or there was a study that came
out recently that suggested that we
could actually figure out a person's ATM
password simply through reading EEG
information from their brain and there
are companies that are already piloting
using devices like this in the workplace
to try to measure productivity and
insurance companies who are piloting
having truck drivers wear them because
the leading cause of accidents in this
country is drowsy driving not drunk
driving that's all wonderful in the
potential upside but there's no
protection right now no legal protection
no constitutional protection no
structure in society that gives you any
form of privacy over your neural
function and just like through Bluetooth
I could read his brain activity if he
was wearing the device or if I forced
him to wear the device as part of his
employment force is a strong word there
Bluetooth technology governs a lot of
the different consumer base tDCS devices
what happens if somebody hacks into it
what happens if somebody starts lapping
your brain take the device off that's
the first thing you should do right but
these are the kinds of questions that we
have to start asking are there privacy
concerns are there context in which we
shouldn't be using it is it cheating if
you use it in particular context like a
school study or a school setting these
are all the types of things that I think
we need to be talking about more product
Michael earlier we were talking about
ETCs and other ways people try and
stimulate their brain and we I think
you've all used the analogy of the cup
of coffee and is the the electric brain
simulation
better than being caffeinated up in some
tasks yes alright so there was a recent
study done by a colleague of mine named
Andy McKinley who's at the Air Force
research labs one of the smart truly
bright guys coming up in this field what
Eddie did was he sleep deprived people
for 30 hours and did cognitive testing
the whole time right so you were talking
about rich was talking about subjects
being blinded these were also very good
subjects right that stayed in the lab to
do this after 30 hours of sleep
deprivation they got either brain
stimulation no brain stimulation or
caffeine people who got brain
stimulation were good at tasks that were
administered that hour one is called the
Mackworth clock test I don't know if you
guys have ever heard or seen of this but
it is the very definition of dull and
boring right so what this task does is
it takes a little dot and it runs it
around a screen like this in clock
positions and every once in a while it
skips one
when it does that you have to press a
button every time it skips people who
underwent brain stimulation we're good
at this task for it six hours after
stimulation people who got coffee we're
good for between 30 minutes and two
hours and people who got no stimulation
went immediately to sleep not really
because Andy kept them awake but they
they certainly felt like it Andy did
additional tests where caffeine and
brain stimulation had roughly similar
effects so when we're talking about the
magnitude of the effect here and Neeta
and I were talking about this backstage
earlier is that I can't download
information into your brain using this
thing yes but what I can do is I can
push your natural abilities what's I can
tell you one thing that we're doing
right now that has a way bigger effect
than tDCS and that is speaking to you so
if I told you the scallops are really
good or I measured your brain activity
looked at the difference between eating
scallops and eating steak plus it placed
it on your head and then stimulated to
try to push your preference toward
scallops I'd be still be more successful
with speech fascinating did you have a
device with you yes they did well I have
the electrodes yeah so it's a very
simple device and the electrodes are
super important because right now we
have a ton of data that tells us about
how good these things are cognitively
but you really have to take care of the
skin so it's a very simple device right
this has
electrodes on the inside right and then
on the outside and here are the holders
this holders flexible can put it in any
conformation you might want we simply
chose this pentagonal arrangement
because it mimics what most other people
do by putting the electrode in one spot
and so you simply take this thing and
you put it on different spots in the
head to influence different kinds of
behavior right so this is one of the
things that's super critical for
applying this right is that different
spots in the head do different things so
if you want to apply change function a
you'd have electrode configuration a you
want to do configuration B you'd have
electric configuration B so what you see
here is you see somebody actually
performing these target identification
tasks with the electrodes on their head
and this is just cane it was in my lab
she told me to tell you she's awesome
she really did something that to tell
you that if I if her picture went up on
the screen here it's kind of funny but
anyway she just is performing this task
what she's doing there is all the red
circles that you see where the red and
the yellow overlap those are correct
choices and where the there's a yellow
alone
those are mis identifications and where
there's red alone she's identified
something as a target when it's really
not alright so we give the subjects
immediate feedback as they're going
through the task as part of the training
now before everyone in the audience
rushes out the
they're electrodes in their battery you
have some safety concerns here I have
big safety concerns here and I'll tell
you mostly why what we have is we have a
whole bunch of data on tolerability but
not a lot of data on safety okay and
there's a subtle but important
difference tolerability means we can
apply this to people and at the end of
the day there's still a walkie-talkie
they get up from their chair they walk
away and they continue to talk normally
right that's what we know there is not
one single study out there who has taken
electrical brain stimulation done a
whole bunch of good neuroimaging before
stimulation applied the stimulation done
some more neuroimaging applied some more
stimulation done some more neuroimaging
and said thumbs up there are no
detrimental changes to the brain that we
see write a diet study does not exist
and so we need to do that kind of work
before we can say it's both safe and
hour before it's tolerable and safe
right now we have a lot of data on
tolerability not safety do we ever do
that with drugs I mean do we ever get
that kind of like no detrimental effects
anywhere in the brain you know for for
really anything we don't get that kind
of like here's the baseline before
anybody ever took it too you know lots
and lots of applications here's
afterwards it seems like a slightly
higher level of expectation of safety
than we have with existing devices and
existing drugs that are on the
marketplace well I can tell you what I
think is normal and that's the standard
I'd like to see and I mean I it's a
standard that I kind of
by right because I test every device
I've ever used on me before I put it on
another human being and I have the scars
to prove you can be dumb about how you
apply this because I have burned my
forearm up and down by applying these
electrodes in a bad way oh and you can
see this fear this is a series of
electrodes that we tested as we were
going through to develop the one that I
showed you a minute ago which and
afterwards if you want to see it you can
come up and look at so on the left are
conventional sponge electrodes applied
to my forearm right here all right and
what you can see at the end it's not
super clear but it's I hope it's you can
see this is their raised areas and
there's redness and that's on the scalp
if and it's hidden by hair most of the
time when it's not hidden by hair you
can see this on people's foreheads
alright so we tried some different kind
of electrodes also cause plenty of
redness if this in the third column
where you see the electrode that's part
and part square bottom row you can see a
a spot on my skin there that is
discolored it's brown right well that
when they wiped the conductive paste off
of my arm that plug of tissue about the
size of a dime wiped away just like and
it had kind of the consistency of snot
all right so you can do that and I said
I so I had a dime sized hole in my arm
for a couple of weeks and people kept
telling me I should bandage it and I
kept saying I can see my muscles move
down there it's kind of cool yeah so and
then we went through a whole series of
other electrodes until we got to the
ones that we use in the lab now and are
used by the Air Force as well that the
most the are the most mark they leave is
the pressure mark from the Rings right
almost no redness almost no sensation
and I can tell you all about them in
incredibly boring detail but basically
we spent a lot of money and time trying
to make sure that we can at first
principles care for the skin so that we
could deliver this to the brain a
question for you all so if you learn a
function while using one of these
stimulation methods when when you no
longer have that current going on are
you still able to perform at the
enhanced level Richard you wanted I
think most of these techniques I I don't
do this kind of research myself because
before I read I'm retired now this stuff
came up came along after I retired if I
wasn't retired I probably would be
working on this but it's my
understanding that the stimulation often
occurs before the task is done kind of
warm up the brain in this sense isn't
there isn't that right well there's two
kinds of stimulation yeah right so one
is called online stimulation online
stimulation means that the training and
the tasks are simultaneous there's
offline stimulation awful and
stimulation means that you precede the
task with stimulation okay and there's
two different ideas there so you can
feel this right you can feel it on your
skin the electrical stimulation so
there's a problem there scientifically
and that is that if
no it's on the placebo effect is that
Maximum Overdrive and so you may do
better just because there's somebody
that's doing something uncomfortable to
your skin it's preventing you from
falling asleep during these boring tasks
right so what we do is a sham procedure
where we ramp up the current and ramp it
back down we make sure the subjects
blind we make sure the blind in this
case doesn't mean putting something over
your eyes blind in this case means
ignorant all right so that they don't
know what stimulation condition they're
receiving either active or sham blyat we
also run the electrode connectors
through box that has wiring in it that's
obscured by an opaque lid a but opaque
box with an opaque lid so that the
person plugging in the machine doesn't
know if electricity is actually moving
through the box and into the subject so
we double blind everything in this way
we also do within subject studies within
subject studies means that the same
person who gets sham treatment gets
active treatment and we cross them over
so that the order is randomized when we
do that if you learn something during
stimulation the memory is a memory like
every other memory and it sticks with
you all right if we took the tasks that
dr. Hyer showed us earlier with the two
back remembering the position of the
lighted blocks and the tic-tac-toe
diagram you that you're not there trying
to teach somebody something what you're
trying to do there is enhance something
called working memory that I often call
pizza memory right so pizza memory is
basically in the days when there were
phone books which I remember right you
would look
the number in the phonebook you'd repeat
it to yourself while you walked over to
the phone and then date myself again you
would dial into the phone and hopefully
you could remember the number and if
that number if you'd if you were to
pizza every day you to remember the
number if you ordered pizza once a month
you wouldn't remember the number and you
have to hold it in memory and that's
call that's part of the working memory
we can enhance working memory during
stimulation or with stimulation that
precedes the task and afterwards you go
right back to baseline so let me just
raise one issue which is just to take
that and consider if your physician did
well in medical school and pass the
medical boards via tDCS or some other
form of enhancement and then stopped
doing that once they pass the boards and
were your position would you be psyched
about going to that person and would you
think that they were misrepresenting
what their actual medical training was
and this is one of the issues that's
actually happening is people are using
these forms of enhancement while they're
in school and then they get out of
school they're no longer using it maybe
they have things in working memory but
their skills and their abilities may not
actually be fairly represented by the
types of degrees and accomplishment that
they have behind their name so kind of
ethical conundrum that arises from your
question does that also hold for for
chemical stimulants things improve focus
yeah I mean in fact chemical stimulants
are what are much more common today and
caffeine of course being the one that
were the most comfortable with but lots
of drugs like ritalin adderall
modafinil the people are using today or
things people are using temporarily
while they're in a kind of competitive
stage of life then they get to the next
stage of life and we think and rely upon
those types of different types of
credentials which might not actually
represent their skills or abilities so
you gave a an incredible demonstration
there about privacy issues around this
and and the lack of regulation that's
going on but this this is not a drug
there are applications we're talking
about in the medical field but when
you're talking about performance where
would you see regulations coming from
where what part of government might be
responsible for regulating well the
student drug administration is in fact
looking at these devices to consider
whether or not to regulate them whether
it falls within the Food and Drug
Administration's purview depends on
whether or not they are classified as
medical devices that's why the company
that you were noticing earlier with the
slide focus fo dot see us focus they are
sort of trying to stay under the radar
by claiming that they're for gaming
purposes rather than for enhancement
purposes and if they're gaming purposes
then they're not a medical device
because they're not intended for the use
of diagnosis or treatment to the disease
once the FDA says hey that's a sham game
that isn't going to work with us and
that's actually a medical device it
could fall within their purview and then
it would be part of what they would
actually regulate I just want to add
that if you are undergoing surgery you
might want your surgeon to be wearing
one of these devices and if they're not
if there's research that shows they can
perform better if your surgeon chooses
not to do that and there's a mistake is
he guilty of malpractice for not putting
so so that leads to this this question
after you the standard okay question
dumb cop to all of you what is your
prediction for where these technologies
will take us fifty years from now is
that where it's gonna take us I have
kind of this secret fantasy that I'll be
transported 50 years into the future to
see how this all comes out wouldn't that
be great
because we could be completely wrong
about this fifty years from now it could
be very common as common as a cup of
coffee I don't think these things can be
banned
it's like banning alcohol I don't think
they should be banned I think we should
just
we need to deliberate about what the
appropriate context use and you know if
regulation regulation is to ensure that
they're safe that they're effective that
we get the kind of information we need
to understand if you apply it that you
may end up with you know being able to
see your muscles without intending to do
so like you know if it really works and
it really works to a noticeable degree
then parents are going to demand the
right to give this technology to their
children they're gonna demand it it's
just such a trickier area because giving
it to your child is not the same as
influencing and shaping their brain and
ways that we were never able to do
before now that's what all new
technology does but it's a little a
little harder when you're talking about
the relationship between parent and
child versus a consenting adult who has
the competency capacity to make
decisions for themselves and to be
self-directed about what they choose to
do as opposed to a parent making a
potential little psychopath
here's
here's a question from Natalia who is in
the off-site audience in Manila in the
Philippines can any of these treatments
improve focus for people with ADHD is
research there's actually been some
research on these devices these EEG
devices some of the studies suggest that
doing neurofeedback playing you know
games attentional games with these may
be more effective than using drugs like
adderall and Ritalin
that in fact neurofeedback changes your
brain and can change our brain
permanently as well so there are some in
that eye and tDCS I know that there's
been some ADHD studies as well if you
wanna yeah there's three there right now
there are three trusts three studies
that show positive results and there's a
clinical trial going on fourth if for
ADHD at NIH that's funded by NIH so I
don't believe it's done yet but we'll
know the results of that in the next
couple of years for sure so Bob Bob
Yaffe wants to know about adverse
effects over the long run for TMS and
and PVCs and and and I'll ask you
specifically Michael you know you're
using this in in the military are there
concerns that what what is giving a
positive benefit right now in terms of
identifying targets may have a long-term
effect on those people's brains so I
think there's a couple ideas mixed up in
that right so I think tDCS TMS what have
you in terms of brain stimulation it's
gonna be a lot like going to the gym
meaning that if you go once and do the
training once you'll reap the benefits
of going once
nobody wants to get the benefit to go to
the gym once right what that is is sore
muscles for a few days so we're going to
have to think about this in exactly the
terms that are suggested by the person
asking this question what are the
effects of repeated administration over
long periods of time right now we don't
have any good data on
what we know for a fact is that skin
yeah you can't keep delivering it to the
same piece of skin over and over and
over which is problematic because if you
move the electrode you change the piece
of brain that's being stimulated and so
I think there's gonna be a lot of work
and a lot of progress is gonna need to
be made on the electrode skin interface
before we can do a good job of learning
even approaching the problem of what's
it like for long term intervention and
is there concern that the stimulation of
one part of the brain will affect have
untoward consequences and in an in
another part of the brain there's no
question that the brain is not simple
it's not that one spot on the brain does
one thing and a different spot does
something else a lot of people think
this is the way the brain works but in
fact even for the most simple task areas
all over the brain are orchestrated so
if I tell you press a button when the
light comes on and I brain and I do a
brain image with the technology that
shows me what's happening in your brain
millisecond by millisecond in the half
second it takes you to press the button
you will see all all areas of the brain
are lighting up it's really quite
phenomenal the brain is not simple when
people to ask me this question I asked
him where is right turn in a car is it
in the hands is that in the brains and
in the wheels of a steering linkage
where is it right turn is the group of
things working together and so by
analogy if you put better tires on the
car that might be what tDCS is if you
put better steering wheel or a better
linkage that might be what TVCs helps
but you can help any way along that path
where you decide to stimulate right but
just because you're helping right and so
you might improve your steering well but
if the steering wheel comes at the cost
of the brake pedal yep right that's a
problem
right and so I think the question was
really what one do you choose it breaks
or you have a great new steering wheel
and maybe we don't know that's that's
one of the questions that we don't know
and and that's one of the frightening
parts of it is repeated stimulation may
improve one function in the brain it may
come at the cost of decrease activation
in another region of the brain it is all
integrated which means you may have much
broader impacts all over you know the
brain and meaning distributed functions
are going to be impacted or could be a
specific skill set or specific type of
thing like emotion is very significantly
impacted while you're improving a
particular type of cognition well get
some hints when gamers using these
things show up at the emergency room
that's true or in jail right go on that
Pleasant expose we are we are just about
out of time and I want to thank our
three panelists for what I I found to be
a really stimulating
[Music]